[Musique]
nous sommes le mardi 3 janvier 2017
bonsoir bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 les invités une émission
dédiée à celles et ceux qui font
l'actualité vous en avez l'habitude vous
entendrez aujourd'hui thibault marshall
c'est le créateur du groupe d'appui
insoumis de guyancourt il mène
actuellement la campagne de la france a
soumises de jean-luc mélenchon
il sera aussi candidat aux prochaines
élections législatives dans le
département et puis julien omnes c'est
l'un des organisateurs du festival
bubble ce cas et qui débute dans
l'agglomération un festival dédié à la
bande dessinée est proposé dans le
réseau des médiathèques
bonsoir à tous les deux et bienvenue sur
ce plateau on va commencer avec vous
thibault marshall représentant local de
jean luc mélenchon va vous présenter
comme ça assemblée constituante
transition écologique changions
diplomatique
à quoi ressemblerait la france dirigée
par jean luc mélenchon vous avez déjà
tracé les grandes lignes
effectivement la première la première
grande réforme entre guillemets que nous
nous fait tant elle est républicaine
c'est là que l'assemblée constituante
il s'agit de redonner le pouvoir au
peuple et pas uniquement dû faire voter
sur une nouvelle constitution
je pense qu'on est plusieurs à critiquer
les institutions de la vème république
mais nous on veut aller plus loin avec
de nouveaux droits révocation des élus
est véritablement la convocation d'une
assemblée populaire qui va décider des
règles de la façon dont nous allons
vivre ensemble puis le deuxième grand
chantier social avec l'abrogation de la
loi elle comrie avec la hausse immédiate
du smic à 1300 euros net par mois
voilà des grandes mesures j'allais dire
classique de la gauche
malheureusement on est obligés de dire
que c'est ça la gauche parce que le
gouvernement sortant n'a pas
véritablement mener ce genre de deux
mesures et puis le dernier grand volet
c'est l'environnement l'environnement la
transition énergétique la planification
de cette transition avec 100% d'énergies
renouvelables non seulement parce qu'on
peut le faire mais parce qu'on doit le
faire dans la journée l'agencé le
candidat écologiste aujourd'hui à
aujourd'hui c'est le candidat écologiste
son programme notre programme l'avenir
en commun et pour la sortie du nucléaire
progressive mais sortie définitive du
nucléaire pour 100 % d'énergie
renouvelable pour la planification
écologique la règle verte dans la
constitution oui votre candidat
aujourd'hui et est autour de 11 14 %
selon les les différents sondages il
avait obtenu un peu plus de 11% c'était
en 2012
mais quelle marge de progression il a
sur les prochains mois nous on travaille
pour qu'il gagne donc la marge de
progrès cela vous mordez sur le terrain
des verts alors présenté comme le
candidat de will mael idéal sa vérité
que les verts au lieu de faire une
primaire entre
sans succès malheureusement pour eux
décident de de partir avec nous on leur
avait proposé gens qui participent à la
primaire de la gauche non non nous on
était content le principe des primaires
on l'avait dit dès le départ il ya un an
quand jean luc mélenchon a annoncé sa
candidature et même les années
précédentes on expliquait que ce système
il n'avait pas vocation à rassembler les
gens dégoûtés de la politique mais
uniquement à faire voter ceux qui s'y
intéresser et ce qu'ils étaient on va
dire d'un capital culturel social
supérieur finalement les classes
populaires les classes les plus
nombreuses dans la société
un qui représentent la plus grande part
de la population active ne se prononçait
pas leur lors de ce genre de scrutin
payant en plus donc pour nous c'est pas
une bonne façon de désigner candidat
les primaires donc et pour plein
d'autres raisons du coup nous on voulait
un grand mouvement un grand
rassemblement jean luc mélenchon étaient
ceux proposés comme porte parole et
ensuite on a travaillé sur un programme
en commun pendant plusieurs mois avec un
groupe d'animation qui a recueilli
toutes les propositions en ligne et qui
a actualisé le programme de la dernière
fois il ya une campagne qui est très
tourné sur les réseaux sociaux aussi qui
se joue beaucoup sur les réseaux sociaux
jean luc mélenchon a même sa chaîne sur
internet sur l'hygiène qui qui séduit
plutôt pas mal la première chaîne
politique c'est d'attirer les plus
jeunes aussi par ce biais là oui enfin
les plus jeunes pas uniquement parce que
quand on regarde un petit peu justement
qui va sur sur youtube voir jean luc
mélenchon il ya vraiment de toutes les
catégories d'âge du moins ceux qui ont
internet et qui entend sont familiers
mais l'objectif surtout ces deux d'avoir
un format différent de des émissions
qu'on trouve dans les émissions
télévisées classique parce que les
émissions télévisées classique le bal le
choix des questions n'est pas le nôtre
déjà c'est travaillent les journalistes
améliorer normalement mais non mais non
mais l'idée c'est aussi de parler de
sujets qui nous semble plus intéressant
et qui sont pas forcément qu'il soit le
dire mais l'agenda folle épopée récente
je dis pas ça je dis que toutes les
questions sont pas toujours dans
l'agenda politique et que les gens les
journalistes qui font leur métier ils
travaillent sur l'actualité direct et
nous on veut apporter des thématiques
qui sont pas forcément dans l'actualité
direct et puis parfois ça prend plus de
sept minutes ou 10 minutes ou un quart
d'heure ça
en deux heures sur sa chaîne youtube
mélenchon il met ses discours qui dure
deux heures voilà donc ça c'est un
format le numérique qui permet de passer
des thématiques dont on parle peu et des
formats en terme de temps inhabituel et
les gens regardent les deux heures de
vidéo bah oui à priori en tout cas voilà
c'est la première chaîne politique sur
youtube
jean luc mélenchon c'est aussi notre
livre le deuxième livre le plus vendu de
la période
le troisième cadeau de noël des français
qui sont au programme voilà il n'ya pas
que le numérique il ya encore le papier
pour l'instant dans les différents
sondages jean luc mélenchon et devant le
candidat désigné de la gauche on ne
connaît pas encore son nom la primaire
n'a pas eu lieu mais en tout cas que ce
soit manuel valls et arnaud montebourg
il est pour l'instant devant donc vous
nous disiez c'est pour vous c'est lui
qui incarne la gauche aujourd'hui
pourtant dans les idées de gauche il ya
peut-être une idée sur lequel j'aimerais
qu'on revienne c'est celle du revenu
universel qui est plutôt une idée à la
base de gauche benoît hamon la défense
notamment jean luc mélenchon la france
insoumise n'est pas du tout favorable
oui ça a donné lieu d'ailleurs il ya sur
la chaîne youtube me semble-t-il
ailleurs une vidéo là dessus donc
charles girard et jacques généreux qui
était co organisateur de la construction
de notre programme avec jean luc
mélenchon ont reçu différents experts
pas toujours d'ailleurs de gauche qui
sont venus expliquer leur position et il
ya eu une vraie discussion autour de
cette problématique du revenu universel
ou du salaire du salaire à vie alors
pourquoi lorsque l'on se pose est
pourquoi être contre
alors le problème pour nous c'était de
mettre au coeur au coeur tout de même
des revenus
la problématique de l'emploi et le
revenu de base revenu universel etc etc
aujourd'hui tel qu'il est entendu la
plupart d'ordre dans la plupart des pays
qui le test c'est plutôt remplacer
toutes les aides possibles parce revenus
pour ensuite dire les pauvres on
s'occupe de vous vous êtes assisté
arrêtez de nous embêter voilà et nous
c'est pas du tout la logique que l'on
cherche ce que l'on cherche et pas
uniquement de se débarrasser de la
problématique de la pauvreté comme ça et
de la mettre sous un tapis et ensuite
les gens ne
on s'occupe plus d'eux mais au contraire
de travailler sur des politiques de
remise à l'emploi
voilà comment ça se passe sur le terrain
concrètement si on a envie en bassin
évinois aujourd'hui alors que représente
la france insoumise dans le département
alors votre secteur voilà dans le
département on a plusieurs groupes
d'appui locaux il y en a des plus actifs
que d'autres on milite bas de façon
traditionnelle donc les affiches ont
distribué des tracts évidemment on a
organisé notamment beaucoup dans le nord
du département à conflans sainte
honorine ce qu'on appelait des caravanes
insoumise dans les quartiers populaires
il s'agissait là de faire une campagne
d'inscription sur les listes électorales
mais aussi de l'information des gens sur
leurs droits sociaux puisqu'on sait
qu'il ya une grande partie des gens qui
ont droit au rsa et qui ne le demande
pas et donc leur expliquer comment on
demande le rsa quels sont les critères
il n'y a pas que le rsa d'autres aides
sociales donc c'était vraiment une
campagne de ré approprier
réappropriation des droits sociaux et
des droits politiques des gens et puis
il ya la vente du jour du livre du
devoir les voilà sur les marchés ont
refait sa ce week end notamment dans le
mantois faire campagne juste en rang de
mots dans le département des yvelines ce
n'est pas forcément une chose facile le
territoire yvelinois n'est n'est pas
profitable à la gauche alors c'est sûr
que
si on regarde le score aux élections
départementales la dernière fois la
gauche a disparu de l'antenne on voit la
conséquence d'ailleurs sur les pmi la
fermeture massive de tous ces centres
locaux de services publics
malheureusement avec une hausse dès des
impôts en même temps on se demande où va
l'argent
mais sur le débat sur la peine et les
dotations mais voilà les femmes en ont
effectivement on n'aurait pas le temps
mais on va s'arrêter sur un format de 7
minutes
alors voilà c'est juste pour finir sur
votre question je pense que ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui le département et de
droite c'est aussi le fait massif d'une
abstention des personnes qui pourraient
voter pour nous et l'objectif c'est de
convaincre les gens qui ne votent plus
et non pas de voter les électeurs de
gauche où les électeurs de droite vont
rester avec nous on va changer de sujet
parce que faire de la politique ne
s'oppose pas au fait d'aimer le neuvième
art la bande dessinée c'est peut-être
votre cas mais julien omnes bonsoir soit
le 9e art bubble sky la bande dessinée à
l'honneur à partir d'aujourd'hui
jusqu'au 18 février dans le réseau des
médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines avec des expositions des
rencontres des ateliers c'est aussi bien
ouvert aux bédéphiles coco qu'aux
néophytes l'objectif c'est quoi
justement c'est de faire venir un public
très vaste danser dans ce réseau des
médiathèques l'objectif tout d'abord
c'est déjà de remettre en place un
événement qui existe depuis très
longtemps surtout des médiathèques sur
la période à savoir accompagner un peu
ce qui se passe à angoulême à notre
niveau beaucoup plus un vrai bien
bizarrement parallèle du festival
d'angoulême sous les noms cette année on
développe beaucoup plus le système du
conte a créé cet événement de toute
pièce belle sky avec un nouveau nom avec
un nouveau visuel donc on sait si je
peux me permettre expression beaucoup
plus éclaté
déjà dans la construction de tout ça et
ça permet d'avoir une chose de beaucoup
plus riches beaucoup plus visible aussi
et puis bah on a créé entre autres des
partenariats ces particuliers notamment
avec des maisons d'édition
donc on a une super expo comme vous
l'avez dit qui apparaît dès l'année des
loges dès demain d'ailleurs au brésil
dès demain adventure times qui est une
série très sympa qui nous vient des
états unis qui sera sur quel médiathèque
sur tout le réseau
elle va être sur quatre mitec différents
et elle commence aujourd'hui au canal et
au 7 mars si je dis pas de bêtise ça à
élire site internet ans je vous
interromps mais qui s'affiche sur lequel
on peut retrouver l'intégralité de mes
programmes
voilà absolument vides aux médiathèques
vous avez ces petits cpie marque page
qui permet d'avoir le plus gros des
infos
c'est intéressant parce que c'est urban
comics la maison d'édition qui nous a
créé cette expo spécifiquement pour pour
la période donc on est très content et
puis urban notamment à bosser avec enfin
à bosser non mais nous a envoyé des
cartons des cartons de bd est comme ça a
été le cas avec les humanoïdes associés
comme aussi les éditions soleil qui nous
permettent de mettre en place cette
année un gros quiz à l'échelle du
territoire donc toujours sur les sites
internet
on pousse tous les adhérents les usagers
et puis ceux qui ne le sont pas de venir
nous voir de participer à ça pour
essayer de gagner des lots
il ya un engouement véritablement autour
de la de la bande dessinée vous le
ressentez dans le réseau des
médiathèques qui a une vraie demande les
aficionados viennent vous voir
alors oui absolument l'engouement je
sais pas parce que l'engouement ça sonne
un petit peu ça semble un petit peu
événement local toute l'année moi j'ai
des gens de tous âges qui viennent me
voir j'ai beaucoup d'enfants qui sont
fans de la bd parce que c'est le public
un peu cliché mais au-delà de ça j'ai
aussi énormément de gens de tous âges
qui vont de 25 ans jusqu'à 75 ans qui
viennent me voir qui me demandent des
conseils
il n'y a pas de sexe et y'a pas d'âge
pour aimer la bd et ça vraiment j'y
tiens parce que c'est la seule réalité
de ce média ça vous dire que aussi que
vous au sein du réseau des médiathèques
vous faites une veille sur ce style très
large je parle du 9e art parce qu'il ya
un manque un comics bd ça c'est très
très large roman graphique c'est vous
avez tout dit on préparé tout donc vous
faites une veille et vous renouveler
régulièrement les stocks et une
évolution aussi de la façon de faire de
la bd c'est la base du travail de
médiathécaires comme pour tous les fonds
que ce soit les différents romans polars
essais etc
ce soit pour les documentaires pour la
bande dessinée effectivement sur ces
trois grandes entrées que son manga
comics dont venant des états unis et
bande dessinée on a une veille
permanente qui est quasiment du
quotidien avec des nouveaux arrivages
tous les mois des nouveautés tous les
mois qui arrivent dans les nouveaux
équipements et qui sont mis en avant par
les collègues on peut re montrée
peut-être ce petit marque pages que vous
aurez si vous vous rendez dans l'une des
médiathèques du réseau sur à saint
quentin en yvelines et le réseau qui est
encore plus l'argent maintenant avec
l'arrivée des nouvelles communes
progressive
de saint quentin en yvelines au fur et à
mesure les temps forts peut-être les
temps forts alors les temps forts cela
avait parlé de cette exposition mais il
n'ya pas que c'est techniquement les
temps forts effectivement tout d'abord
on a une jeune auteur qui s'appelle alex
qui va venir dans cinq équipements qui
va contribuer a co créé avec les usagers
une bande dessinée sur l'ensemble du
réseau pour ça c'est notre gros temps
fort ça commence le 14 janvier à
elancourt et âme à nice on enchaîne le
21 on à la conclusion le 18 février et
donc effectivement l'objectif et pendant
deux heures dans chaque lieu d'avoir les
adhérents qui propose une suite voilà on
part d'une intro il propose une suite et
pendant deux heures on va créer une
somme de planches ou en tout cas cet
auteur alex va créer une somme de
planches qui sera suivie dans chaque
nouvel équipement sur donc cinq lieux
évidemment une édition la fin tout sera
compilé alors pour la compilation on est
encore en réflexion là dessus pour
l'instant ce qui est certain c'est que
ça trouvable sur le site internet et
médiathèques ça c'est une certitude
pour le reste chaque chose en son temps
on verra comment on fait pour donner sa
de la manière la plus large possible
pour l'instant la seule certitude c'est
internet google sky le festival bd à
saint quentin en yvelines qui débute
aujourd'hui jusqu'au 18 février le
programme sur le site internet qui s'est
affichée puis bien sûr nous reviendrons
régulièrement dans le cadre de nos
différentes éditions du journal sur les
événements que vous allez proposer parce
qu'ils sont nombreux création de bd
il ya également les expositions et puis
des quizz pour gagner ces bd aussi merci
d'être venu nous présenter rapidement ce
festival bubble sky qui débute merci
également aux thibault marshall pour la
france insoumise nous parlions politique
au début de cette édition édition à
revoir en intégralité sur notre site
internet très belle soirée
[Musique]